hey Luke Tom Natan Jacob here at the
altar boys YouTube channel and today
we're showing you some tips about
traveling with kids
[Applause]
hey welcome to another episode of
outdoor boys YouTube channel today we
are traveling this is part of our 2018
World Tour where we are spending a month
traveling we have literally purchased 29
airline tickets and we will be using
them all over the course of 30 days so
needless to say we are traveling a lot
and Tommy here's five mates three and
Jacobs six months old so we are a
glutton for punishment and in this video
we're gonna show you some tips and
tricks for traveling with kids so guys
one thing this video is not going to be
is a tutorial on how to make your kids
behave I don't know anything about your
kids you're the expert now
what I am gonna show you is how to
travel a little less stressed and a
little bit better rested make things go
a little bit easier because if you are
fully charged and running on all
cylinders you're gonna be able to handle
your kids better than anybody else so
that's what this is really about making
travel easier for you as a parent and
then your kids are gonna have a better
time because you're on your a-game one
of the biggest causes of stress when
traveling with kids it's your luggage
okay just hauling it around packing and
unpacking it's all stressful so keep it
light keep it simple keep it organized
and some of the things that really help
is keeping everything in these
individual pack bags so we have three
small kids and this is the suitcase for
all the kids stuff and we've got all
these clear giant Ziploc bags got them
for like half a dozen for 13 bucks and
each boy has his own bag we have stuff
for you know swim clothes we have stuff
for church clothes out all that stuff
and it just makes your life easier when
you're unpacking and packing at the
hotel another thing to remember is that
you can check car seats and booster
seats for free on almost any airlines
additionally umbrella strollers and
other types of strollers you can get
checked for free okay so don't worry
about that bag bring that stuff along
and you can check it it's no additional
cost I highly recommend you get these
big bags to put the car seat in not only
does it help protect the car seat and
make it easier to carry if you have
stuff that
won't quite fit in the luggage you can
take it and throw it in the car seat put
it in the bag and then you got a little
bit of overflow packing remember luggage
causes stress so keep it to a minimum
especially your carry-on so don't bring
a lot of stuff onto the plane because
it'll just weigh you down it's more
things to stress and worry about getting
it up into the overhead bins and where
to store it and oh it's just it's just a
pain it's so much more relaxing to just
walk onto a plane with a very small
little bag this is all the carry ons we
bring for a family of five now you
notice that they're both rollaway bags
okay that is a little thing that makes a
huge difference just not having to carry
it on your back but being able to just
drag it behind you is so much more
relaxing the other thing that really
helps is making sure everything in your
carry-on is organized by little bags
inside using these gallon-sized ziplocks
bags does you two favors first off when
you're going through security it makes
it really easy for your bag to be
searched and then repacked
so it's minimal stress going through
security additionally when you're on the
plane and you need to pull things out of
your bag you're doing it in a cramped
little spot or you're trying to do it in
the overhead bin and the kids are
whining and there's kids someone who's
blown out their diapers and it's just
stressful okay and pulling this stuff
out and digging for something is a huge
pain in the butt if you have everything
in little individual bags when you open
it up you're not gonna have everything
dumping out it just makes your life less
stressful you can't necessarily always
control your kids you can control your
carry-ons my oldest boy Thomas is almost
6 years old so he's old enough to pull
one of these rollaway bags and so we
have the kids stuff in here we have both
the earphones
we've got some stuffed animals and a
blankie we've got the
Kendal's we've got a bag full of snacks
so once again keep things especially
electronic cords all organized by bags
so they don't get all tangled up it's
easier to dig through and find them
we've got sippy cups on the outside
don't over pack it's all we need we
don't need to bring ten billion coloring
books and Legos and things okay this is
the amazon kindle cost about 50 to 80
bucks has a six-hour battery life you
can watch videos on it play games on it
man I absolutely love these things
got one for each boy and if you're a
parent that's concerned about kids
watching too much electronics too much
screen time that sort of thing that's
good right because the less your kids
use a Kindle the more they're going to
love it when they're on the plane right
so reducing their screen time leading up
to the trip will make it so that they
are much much more jazzed to have the
Kindle when they're on the plane if they
would watch the Kindle too much the days
before they'll get bored with all the
stuff on it and then you've kind of
you've used up all your ammo so once
again guys
luggage is not your friends so if you
can get rid of it quickly and easily
that's a good thing so I always use the
curbside assistance or a skycap worth
every penny
sure flying with kids can be stressful
but the worst part is the airport okay
the security lines the check-in worrying
about your fly things getting delayed
kids freaking out carrying all that
luggage that's the worst part that's the
most stressful part most the time so the
more you can eliminate the airport
stresses the better off you're gonna be
and the better mood you're gonna be in
when you finally get up in the skies
you're just gonna have more energy
things gonna be calmer everyone's gonna
be less wound up some of the things you
can do to really minimize stress is
avoid lay overs they are the
I hate layover ok sure you can save a
few bucks by doing a layover it ain't
worth it some other things you can do is
get TSA PreCheck and Global Entry yeah
these are programs the way you can get
pre-screened TSA PreCheck allows you to
walk through security and a special line
which is often much much shorter which
saves you a lot of time and you don't
have to take your shoes off you don't
have to take your belt off you don't
have to remove your laptop you don't
have to remove certain liquids and that
may sound like a little thing but if
you've ever tried to get kids to put
their shoes on it's it's like a
30-minute battle if you can avoid that
battle while standing in line at
security you are gonna eliminate a lot
of stress Global Entry is the same thing
for international flights it's when you
go through immigration and customs you
can skip a lot of that you just go to a
little kiosk it's really quick so you're
gonna fly internationally get Global
Entry you're flying domestically get TSA
PreCheck if you get Global Entry you
automatically get TSA PreCheck so I'll
put a link in the description to some
more information about those two
programs but I'll tell you we got two
Global Entry and TSA PreCheck before
this just trip and it's been worth every
penny every penny man I just it's like
50 bucks to get TSA PreCheck it's 100
bucks to get Global Entry and lasts I
think five years so but if you're gonna
be flying even just once with kids get
at least TSA PreCheck all right we're at
the us-canada border here about to get
back in the good old US of A and there
is a massive massive line so with Global
Entry we get to skip all this line and
do the next thing but hopefully this
will work is our first time doing it
see how it goes
oh that's a long line though holy
mackerel people that was worth every
penny that was a 70 minute wait for
normal people we drove through zero
minute wait we didn't have to fill out
any documentation or anything just talk
to a border agents went through love in
the Global Entry another hard thing
about traveling with kids is they don't
adjust well to time zone changes yeah so
until they do make sure you go to bed
early because they will be waking you up
at 5:00 in the morning
take it easy than when you first land
don't plan any big adventures don't you
know stay up late take it nice and easy
and relaxing and tell your kids get
adjusted then you guys can get into a
better rhythm and get a little bit more
crazy if you have small kids they
require a lot of gear and getting that
gear from one place to another is
stressful so one of the things you can
do to reduce that stress is just order
that stuff online and have it delivered
to your destination so I have two kids
in diapers
and instead of buying those diapers in
Virginia putting them on a plane and
shipping them to wherever we're going I
just went on amazon.com order the
diapers the formula the wipes all that
stuff and have it delivered for free to
our destination and we're gonna be gone
for over a month and so that's a lot of
diapers a lot of wipes and if we shipped
it on the plane we'd have to pay 50
bucks per bag for the extra bag fee each
time we got on the plane that's hundreds
of dollars in baggage fees okay so
instead we can just buy this stuff
online the same price we would buy it
normally and have it shipped for free to
our destinations most hotels will accept
shipments like that and they'll hold it
for you at the front desk a lot of
hotels do that this makes a lot of sense
for bigger items as well such as play
pens and bouncers and things like that
so when Nathan was a little baby we went
on a trip to England and the extra
baggage feed to bring the playpen with
$75 each way that's a hundred and fifty
dollars well you can get
playpen cheap on amazon.com for like 70
bucks so instead of paying a hundred
fifty bucks to ship our playpen to
England we just called up the place told
them that they're gonna be receiving a
package a few days before we got there
and we bought a playpen on amazon.com UK
for 75 bucks and then just left it there
and we came out 75 dollars ahead and the
place was happy to have a free uh
playpen for future guests so a little
bit of planning and a little bit of
online shopping could save you some
serious money and can also save you a
lot of stress when you just arrive at
your hotel and all the baby stuff is
just there waiting for you
a lot of kids get freaked out by
unfamiliar surroundings and have trouble
sleeping if their routine gets broken so
one of the things you can do to prevent
this is sleep bring your kid to sleep in
a tent you can get these little pop-up
tents there's lots of them on the market
we use the the Peapod from KidCo and get
the kids used to sleeping in that you
can have them do a little campout in
their bedroom and if they get used to
sleeping in the tent then you can just
pack up the little tiny kid tent bring
it with you and then they can sleep
anywhere as long as they're inside the
tent now our children's problems have
nothing to do with unfamiliar
environments they're just monsters don't
don't in order to reduce luggage one of
the things you can do is get one of
these little travel booster seats check
this out
there you go a little tiny booster seat
okay with the booster seats isn't really
not about giving them something to sit
on
it's about making the seat belt fit a
smaller body and that's all this thing
does just makes the seat belts and lap
belts hit where they should keeping all
your luggage organized and these little
compartmentalize bags really pays
dividends when you're checking in and
out of a lot of hotels here we are in
Las Vegas we only stayed one night we're
moving on to Los Angeles and very
quickly everything gets pulled out but
you know what it's super easy to repack
because everything's organized the way
it should be all Tommy's clothes are
here all the socks are in there makes
things a lot less stressful one thing
that can help reduce stress when
traveling with kids is keeping all your
reservations and tickets organized and a
little binder one place I'm not really a
binder person I'm not really a very
organized person but when you're got
kids in the car for six hours and you
pull up to your hotel at 10:00 p.m. you
juggle these bags and crap you don't
want to have to be searching for where
is that confirmation number you know
where is the directions to the hotel
where is that phone number you want to
be able to just get it and get checked
in and get it done and have it be
stress-free so just put everything you
need in one binder your whole trip relax
a little bit more you know over and over
again these tips about flying with kids
all revolve around making sure
everyone's rested and not too stressed
out and making things a little bit
easier and right in the middle of that
is make sure you get plenty of sleep
avoid red-eye flight avoid planning too
many activities get the kids down at a
reasonable time and everyone's well
rested then your odds of having a good
flight the next day are just that much
better so let's get you to bed okay if
you like this video don't forget to
check out our 2018 world tour where we
spent five weeks traveling all over Asia
in North America and having all sorts of
great adventures it's a twelve part
series and is
absolutely amazing so don't forget to
click Subscribe for more adventures for
the outro boys YouTube channel and click
the link below to see more videos from
this trip